hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
pfas101 what are they where are they and
how do we test for them
I am Kaylee Bach of lab roots and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labroots and brought to you
by psyx to learn more visit psyx.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click Send we'll answer
as many questions as we have time for at
the end of the presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
I'd like to now welcome our speaker Carl
ochin PhD senior scientist at psyx Carl
you may now begin your presentation
thanks for the introduction hi So today
we're going to be talking about pfas and
this is really meant to be kind of an
introductory talk about what they are
how do we test for them Etc and what are
some tips and tricks that we've learned
along the way to make you as successful
as possible
so when we talk about pfast or we kind
of introduce the topic
um I always like to start with a little
bit about the history so in 2001 there
are two major sort of monitoring studies
that Drew attention to pfas and
ultimately kind of started sounding the
alarm bells of hey this is maybe
something we should look into
so one of those studies focused on sort
of the distribution of pfas across the
globe this was in different mammals
animals Etc
and essentially they found yeah it's
pretty much everywhere from Pittsburgh
to Antarctica we're seeing these
compounds in that study they're looking
at people and pfos
across the globe
and not only that
um but a sort of a follow-up study from
another group looked at it in human
serum and sure enough we found people's
present there so as time has gone on and
we've kind of advanced our monitoring of
these compounds we've we've seen them
spread
um or not necessarily not necessarily
we've seen them spread but we've noticed
that they're spread out and present in
pretty much everywhere
and if we kind of zoom in and take a
second to think about you know
domestically where we're where these
compounds might be located
um if you haven't checked it out it's a
great
great website it's got a cool
interactive map uh ewg where you can
take a peek at where there are known
locations of pfas contamination uh in
the United States and what you'll notice
most likely is that there's probably one
a little bit closer than you'd hope uh
to you and this is certainly true for me
so I'm talking to you from outside
Denver Colorado and you can see Colorado
kind of has a splattering of drinking
water sites that are known to be
contaminated with pfats
so it's an issue uh recently there's
actually a really cool paper that came
out that used
uh some suggestion of locations of where
these compounds are known to propose you
know these are sites we might want to
look into and on even though we have 3
000 sizes or locations that we know
there's pfas contamination this paper
was proposing something like 40 000
sites uh if I remember correctly that we
should be looking into so it's a pretty
diverse problem
so where do they come from
um and the answer is there are a ton of
different sources so some of the main
sources that you probably hear about are
things like military bases airports Etc
and those primarily resolve around
something called a triple F or aqueous
film fire foaming foam so this is a
firefighting foam uh it's pretty complex
it does a really good job at putting out
really tricky fires so these would be
the types of fires you would experience
from say jet fuel in Colorado we do or
we've done quite a bit of hydraulic
fracturing so there's a lot of oil and
gas activities so this type of foam
would be on some sites in case there was
a fire because it was just so good at
sort of putting out these really
difficult fuel fires
but there are a lot of different sources
um you know everything from the
packaging around your hamburger to make
sure your ketchup doesn't soak through
to one of my favorites when I was in
grad school I was working in a pfas lab
and I would often joke that I was going
to bring my skis into the lab to wax
them you know at the time I lived in a
really tiny apartment and it wasn't
super conducive to waxing and sharpening
skis but I had this big old lab bench
um that I could go ahead and use and my
Pi Chris never thought that was funny
and the reason was uh ski wax often
contains fluorine chemicals so that's a
common ingredient in fact every day when
I went to the ski hill from my skis to
you know my snow pants to my snow jacket
we're all waterproof and all contain
floral chemicals even to my breakfast
burrito and its wrapper right so they
surround us they do a really good job at
what they're meant to do anything that's
sort of non-stick you can be a little
suspicious of
um but because they do such a good job
they're pretty persistent
but outside of sort of the you know
scientific Community do people really
care or are they even aware and what you
see is there's been a big uptick in sort
of the public
being interested in these compounds
primarily in water right now
so since 2008 or I'm sorry 2018 we've
seen this increase and there's even a
spike in 2021 and that correlated to
John Oliver doing a piece on HBO where
we saw this big uptick in Google
searches
um so this would just be folks you know
within the scientific Community but also
outside the scientific Community
becoming aware of pfas and becoming
concerned maybe about pfas in their
drinking water
so we need a tool uh we need a tool to
be able to sort of analyze for pfas look
for it and that's where mass
spectrometry comes in so you know
there's commonly sort of this pre
there's this notion that mass
spectrometry is a tool that's used in
only crime labs when a detective needs
to hand you a sort of bag of
mystery substance and you need to report
back what that substance is and somehow
this Mass spectrometer is able to tell
you not only what was in the bag but who
made it when they made it
um and where it came from which we know
right isn't the truth
uh Mass spectrometry plays a really
important role and is key in
understanding this fluorochemical
problem
so we're going to kind of walk through
and touch on just the
brief sort of steps that you go through
in the lab when doing pfas analysis talk
about just sort of some of the tips and
tricks
um and also uh what you might expect if
this is sort of a new assay for you and
you're starting to dive into this world
so first let's start with sample
preparation
so when we think about sample
preparation it's going to vary quite a
bit so there's a lot of talk about
drinking water right now drinking water
is probably the most commonly measured
matrices and I would consider that a
very easy matrices to measure right it's
clean we're not worried about you know a
bunch of different interferences we
shouldn't expect that compared to
something like a landfilled leachate or
a biosolid where we're talking about
really complex matrices
and here I have an example of some food
so this is a project I ran a couple
months ago now where we were looking at
different types of food and we were
trying to figure out what pfas was
present and how much in these different
types of food and the project really
revolved around the question that we had
was you know does more expensive food
you know the free-range ground beef for
example have more pfas than the sort of
cheaper alternatives
but regardless what we see is that even
within these types of matrices so just
take food as an example there's a huge
level of complexity that varies very
much by matrices so the difference
between something that's a little bit
more simple like a cupcake compared to
you know a salmon or a tuna or even a
ground beef there's a lot of variation
there and you'll notice the same thing
even to a smaller extent within drinking
water it can be really variable when
talking about these matrices
so what type of methods exist
um what might you expect for drinking
water we have a few to choose from if
you're looking for sort of an EPA
regulated method the two most common
would be 537
0.1 or just regular 537 which is using
some reverse phase spe or the newer
updated 533 which is a weak ion exchange
but both require some type of sve
and again we're talking about drinking
water so that's great
um we're not super worried about you
know contamination or we are worried
about contamination but we're not
worried about clogging SBE columns et
cetera this is a really clean Matrix
which is great
um and that's what's LED other groups to
sort of uh deviate a little bit from
those methods and do something like a
direct injection uh if possible you know
that that's always kind of the way
Eileen you remove sample prep which
is kind of a step where you can
introduce contamination right you'll
notice that's going to be a theme for
the rest of the talk is how to limit
that
um but it depends on what your goals are
if you're trying to do a regulated
method if you have the ability to sort
of do this amended method
um a little depend on contracts and
again what you're trying to accomplish
when you move into things like soils
methanol extraction is probably the most
common
and then with food catchers so catchers
is a really good approach to sort of
extracting some of these fluorinated
compounds
with serum serum it gets a little bit
more complicated
so a very common approach would be an
online spe you know there's challenges
with that
it's simple once you get it set up but
there's issues with clogging compared to
something like an offline spe
which is what I've seen most folks have
the most success with if they're doing a
lot of samples
so what are the type of compounds we're
even interested in so they'll be sort of
these main two groups that you'll hear
about quite a bit the carboxylic acids
so things like pfoa would be an example
of a legacy compound that would fall in
that group and put coordinated salt and
things so something like pfos which is
sort of the the poster child for for
floral chems
um so those are two really big groups
if you are interested in sort of the
atrial F side of things you'll probably
hear a little bit more about those four
tail more sulfonates which were pretty
common in those uh mixtures
and there's some new compounds there's
replacement products like Gen X
um some really small chain uh floor
chemicals as well so
if you're doing a regular method those
compounds will be kind of spelled out
for you but if you're interested in
doing some of these more screening type
methods that we'll kind of touch on
there's a pretty diverse range of
compound classes Within pfas
but regardless
um they work really well to they're
really amenable to reverse phase
chromatography which is great with the
exception of some of those really small
acids you'll find that something like a
c18 is usually a really good option for
these guys
so what's next
um I I add this slide in just because
people ask about it quite a bit so when
we think about what's coming up
method 1633
that is sort of the the newest EPA
method that is talking about aqueous
samples but moving more away from
drinking water you know what about those
other matrices like biosolids tissues
Etc it's very similar to 533 in the
sense that it's using you know
isotopically labeled standards so it's
doing sort of that isotope dilution type
approach
um
but we're going to be looking at ion
ratios which is kind of interesting a
little bit different
besides just a regulated method several
of you are probably aware
um the EPA listed their health advisory
limit for drinking water and it had pfoa
at four parts per quadrillator right
which is really really low
um so that's kind of a trend we've been
seeing is you know as we understand
these compounds a little bit more we
start looking at them in different
matrices but we also start looking at
lower levels and those levels can be
really challenging we recently released
a tech note with your fins and
phenomenons where you know we looked at
that four parts per quadrillion level
and I can tell you it was no easy task
um so although that's not obviously a
detection limit that the EPA said it's
still it's still interesting and kind of
a trend that I'd expect to continue
so once we move past sort of the sample
preparation we get into the separation
stage and there's some room here to talk
about you know what makes pfasing
analysis unique
so as many of you are almost certainly
aware in hblc uh is really just a
combination of a pump in an auto sampler
in you know a column oven I bring this
up only because we're going to be
talking a lot about contamination
sources within it
so when we think about an hplc pump you
know we're using a mobile phase a and a
mobile phase B typically for pfest we're
talking about water and ammonium acetate
somewhere in the 10 millimolar range uh
and methanol often with the ammonium
acetate as well
um but those solvents are moving through
this pump and they're being introduced
to different lines uh different modules
Etc where contamination can can take
place
and from there they're moving into an
auto sampler and when they make their
way into the auto sampler again they're
coming into contact with things like
sample Loops valves even the vial that
you're using for an injection right are
all the potential sources where you
could have some fluorinated compounds
present
and in fact that's what we see so uh
this is sort of my little cheat sheet
that I give to customers uh when they're
talking about or concerned about
contamination uh in terms of what could
be contaminated big thing would be
plastic tubing so you'll notice that
you'll hear sometimes about pfas kits
and I even have a slide and then the
next slide is about that but essentially
what we're doing is removing all of
those potentially contaminated plastic
tubings things like PTFE
Etc and replacing it with Peak so
something we know doesn't have sort of
those background interferences with pfas
so plastic tubing is huge removing those
Auto sampler vial caps they're often
PTFE lines so replacing that with
something like a polypropylene is also a
really good idea
you know you have your media bottle caps
the big one I'm gonna sort of
talk about
um or bring your attention to is
solvents solvents are a huge source of
contamination when it comes to the LC
portion
um even if you are using sort of the you
know Ultra Pure lcms grade solvent
I've seen issues with them
um so one of the things if you if you
haven't already or if you are having
background contamination issues would be
to take a look at your solvents one of
the easiest ways to do this would just
be to extract yourself in just like a
sample
um so do that sort of extraction blank
step and see what happens
you could also just try switching
solvents and seeing if your background
comes down and it might not be as
obvious as you think there have been
plenty of times in the however many Labs
have been to at this point where I've
seen background decrease
when they switch to their millicue water
instead of your lcms grade water
for example so really testing those
solvents before you get started if
you're having any issues ETC is
something that I would like to kind of
point you in the direction of
there are other minor sources like
pipette tips though
and of course you know that ammonium
acetate that you're adding in could be a
source of contamination
but when in doubt the best thing to do
is you know either replace it or rinse
it with methanol at least three times
so what do these kits look like
um you know this is just an example of
one every LC will have slightly
different amount of tubing than it might
need so this is an example of our exeon
2 LC with our pfas kit and really what
we're replacing are those tubes so
switching to that Peak tubing
um even using stainless steel as an
alternative the one issue that you may
run into with a stainless steel is that
some of those methyl and ethylphosis for
example can stick to metal so you might
want to avoid it if you are really
interested in those but in this case
it's the stainless steel security link
we're using is before a sample would be
injected so it's really not of a concern
and then in terms of what type of
columns you're going to be using you're
actually going to use two columns both
will be the same chemistry
I typically recommend the Luna Omega
psc18 so that c18 chemistry works really
well
but what does that second column do and
why are you using it
so the whole point of that second column
is to sit between your pumps and your
auto sample area
and this is commonly referred to as a
delay column so that's how I'll refer to
it so this delay column is trying to
separate any contamination that's coming
before your auto sampler and what it's
doing is when you're sitting there and
you're in the equilibration step that's
it
and there happens to be some background
in this case it's for pfh acceptance
um that is just kind of moving through
your system right and what we don't want
is when you run your injection uh you
know you inject your sample for that
contamination Peak to come out at the
same time uh as your analytical Peak so
that delay column essentially allows
that compound to build up
um and the loot because it's
for the analytical column and before the
auto sampler it's going to loot later
than your peak of Interest so there's an
example here
of that and if I zoom in to sort of an
example uh off of my lcms in the lab you
can see here we've got the contamination
hump
and that contamination hump is coming
from our hplc
and wasn't removed when we changed over
our pfast kit and likely because it's
being delayed or definitely because it's
being delayed by our delay column it's
coming from either the pumps themselves
or probably the solvent but regardless
with the delay column we're able to
avoid this issue completely we don't
have to worry about it we have good
separation you know we can happily
integrate and continue on our day so if
you're doing pfas analysis this is
something that's sort of uh mandatory
you're going to need a delay column
but
um there are other options or sort of
other sources for uh
contamination so it's not just uh you
know the delay column but also things
like carryover uh so when we think about
carryover uh we typically talking about
the auto sampler right it could be the
column two
um but we're going to really want to
adjust those Auto sampler settings
I've had really good results uh with
just methanol as a rinse but if you find
yourself sort of in this position where
you're having carryover issues adding
something like IPA to the methanol can
be pretty helpful
and then the other thing that I want to
sort of just bring your attention to is
that rinse tubing is likely different
from the tubing from your pumps for
example
so when you take a look at your auto
sampler however it's designed take a
look at that rinse tubing and if you're
having issues with things like carryover
you're going to want to try to replace
that
carryover obviously isn't being impacted
by our delay columns so it's it's a big
problem since it's going to affect our
peak of Interest
here's a little schematic of what that
can kind of look like so if you do see
sort of that consistent
um
carryover regardless of whether you're
injecting you know one part per billion
or one part per million areas where it
could be sort of like stuck between the
needle and its Port so decreasing the
amount of injection volume is usually a
good approach to sort of mitigate this
as much as possible
but what else
um where else can you get contamination
and sometimes it's not as sort of
straightforward as you would think
so in this case we had a customer that I
went out to help and we had a really
high background of pfba
and this was weird for them
um they had been doing pfas analysis for
quite some time now and this wasn't an
issue previously so they couldn't figure
out what was going on
so we did a few things first we made a
fresh blank
that wasn't it
um it wasn't just some sort of dirty
blank we tried a different methanol
source so we tried a different methanol
we also tried a different water source
you know maybe that's where it's coming
from so sort of exploring those solvents
that wasn't the case either
we tried using a different pipette
um that is actually kind of interesting
it can be this pipette tips it also can
be some sloppy pipetting uh I had
another customer site actually we uh had
an issue where randomly they are getting
huge contamination issues with different
sort of pfas analytes so one day it
would be pfos one day it would be pfoa
and Etc
and what actually ended up happening was
there was a lab next door that was
borrowing their pipettes and they were
doing some surface tension experiments
on these compounds and they're using
pure pfoa to do that so when they're
pipetting a little bit got stuck behind
um whether it's sloppy or whatever and
it was causing this analyst a ton of
issues so we tried using a different
pipette but in this scenario that was
not the problem
new column is always an easy one just to
slap on and see if you see any
Improvement but we did not
so we were kind of confused we said all
right let's just flush the system sort
of my go-to thing is to flush it with
methanol and one percent formic acid you
know for 20 or 30 minutes uh does that
help and in this case no
so where is this coming from
so we did just a little experiment where
we walked around the lab and took swabs
of different rooms and what we found is
you know
can't really tell where it's coming from
or blank is pretty similar to the swab
from outside the lab which was pretty
similar to the prep room it doesn't look
like you know if there's any real Source
here and then we went and swabbed the AC
and in this lab it we used to have
issues with sort of the temperature
fluctuations especially in the summer a
lot of big windows it's in Colorado it
gets pretty hot so they went ahead and
installed a mini AC so one of those sort
of
streamlined ACS that sits above the door
and what we found was it was
contaminated with either pfba or
something that had a similar parent in
transition so our signal was really high
so we ended up having to take that apart
rinse it all with methanol rebuild it
remove the filters which were
probably a source of the issue and once
we did we got rid of this problem
but I bring it up uh just to mention
that you know it's not always as
straightforward as you might think
because these compounds are everywhere
from our clothing
um to Foods Etc
um sometimes you have to think a little
bit outside the box when it comes to
contamination issues
in terms of just what does a gradient
look like for pfas it's going to be very
similar or very basic
um to just probably what you're almost
doing now or what you're at least
familiar with we're going to be ramping
from a really low aqueous to retain some
of those uh super polar small chain
floor chemicals we're going to ramp up
and hold it
and we're going to make sure that we
hold it for at least three column
volumes just to clean it off and then
we're going to go back to the
equilibration step where we start at our
starting conditions so in terms of
gradient there's not a ton that you need
to do it's going to be very similar and
probably very familiar to you
let me hold it and it comes back down
so that's kind of the basics of the hplc
hplc system the column Etc let's talk
about the mass spec portion so where it
kind of gets really interesting
so if you're unfamiliar with mass spec
uh there are a few different types of
sort of ionization mechanisms that we
use to introduce these compounds into
our Mass spectrometer
so maybe you're moving from the gcms
world where we would have something like
EI and CI to the lcms world where most
of the time we're talking about
electronic ionization and certainly for
pfas analysis that's where we want to be
so this is really good for those polar
to very polar compounds
uh which is where our fluorochemicals
kind of sit
and we're going to be doing msms so we
are going to be taking a parent
fragmenting it and we're going to be
monitoring for a specific fragment or
daughter I am
um so I'll pretty much talk about triple
quadruples I have a couple slides just
to introduce high resolution Mass
spectrometry but in general a lot of
these methods a lot of what we're
interested in right now is surrounded by
a Quant while there is obviously some
interest in sort of this discovery
portion
foreign
ionization and why do I bring it up so
we're going to be introducing our
compounds through our capillary so we're
going to have these big droplets and we
want to separate those droplets we're
not really interested in or interested
in our solvent for example we want to
remove that so we're going to use things
like our GS2 or our heat temperature to
promote evaporation
and we're going to introduce these into
our quadrupole and to do that we're
going to use something called the
clustering potential the clustering
potential I like to kind of describe as
the energy used to pull in our ion of
Interest
there are a few other variables but in
terms of pfas analysis there's one
that's really important so here's our
sort of typical pfest setup for 7500
system if you're using maybe a 65 55 45
Etc
um you're going to be using a different
Iron spray voltage but for this
instrument this is what works well but
regardless what I really want to bring
your attention to is this temperature
issue
so what you'll notice is that as you
increase sort of your Source temperature
you'll get an increase in intensity of
those sulfonates so those sulfonates
intensity will increase regardless of
the chain length but at the same time
you'll see a decrease in intensity of
those carbosilic acids
so we've really got to kind of pick a
sweet spot right if we picked let's say
600 Degrees for our source temperature
we'd sacrifice a lot of those carboxylic
acids and you know we'd have a great
signal for stuff like pfos but our PFO
signal probably wouldn't be as good as
it could be
um so that's why we compromised in the
300 range so typically you'll see at
least tax methods range from 300 to 400
ish
in terms of source temperature
and that seems to be a good sweet spot
um if you're trying to do diverse lists
obviously if your whole goal is to go
ahead and you know only look at pfos for
example you could go ahead and increase
that Source temperature so a little bit
of a compromise there
um based on the chemical classes
so let's just kind of go through what an
mrm experiment is and why we're even
doing it
um so if this is new to you you know why
do we care
um and what's happening so let's say in
step one we have a compound of interest
it's 215 this is a fluorinated compound
though we want to monitor for so what
are triple quadrupole or a q trap is
doing is it's allowing at 215 to make
its way through q1
while the other ions are being filtered
out
once it's made its way through q1 and
into Q2 that's where fragmentation will
take place so we'll get some fragments
created
and then we will do the same thing when
we're monitoring for a specific item and
that ion is being passed through Q3 on
our sway to our detector the others are
being filtered out so if you think about
that we're being really really specific
much more specific than if maybe you're
used to doing gcms and looking for a
specific ion like a Sim method
foreign
why not just use the mass of the
compound that's pretty specific already
and I like to kind of show this example
so here's some Ms data I've got my
standard
and I'm looking at these two compounds
so there's two isomers here that I'm
interested in one at nine one at nine
and a half
and in my Matrix blank this is a plant
sample I have those sort of these
interferences that surround my compound
of Interest
which is no good and when I Spike my
sample on top of it what you'll notice
is hey
uh my Peaks are co-looting I can't
really accurately integrate what I'm
interested in uh and based on the way my
Matrix blank looks I might even sort of
accidentally uh integrate those as true
Peaks and report a false positive which
is something we would never want to do
right
um so this Ms data just isn't cutting it
just using the mass alone just isn't
enough
but when we look at that mrm data we see
those interferences have disappeared so
those interferences are gone which is
great that's our goal so we've got our
compound of Interest nothing in our
Matrix blank and our Spike sample so
whatever that interference was yes it
shared the same parent Mass but the
structure was different so when we
fragmented it in Q2
we didn't get the same fragments the
fragment we were monitoring for wasn't
present
and therefore we don't see it so it's
really important especially for pfas
analysis and I've got an example of that
that we monitor for these fragments
so what can we kind of expect or see
um when it comes to some of these
fragments so I like to draw attention to
to this issue of uh the SO3 fragment
which is a mass at 80.
so for pfos that's probably the the
fragment you'll see monitor the most
especially in drinking water methods
but that's not an appropriate fragment
to measure measure if you're getting
into something like food for example so
on the right I have an example of a 100
per trillion standard
for pfas and a snack cake and what
you'll see is that it looks like if I
were monitoring the 499 to 80 fragment
that there's a ton of pfos in my snack
cake this would be really concerning you
know
parts per billion maybe even parts per
million levels would be you know this
would be a huge issue if that was truly
pfas but when I look at my second
transition 499 to 99 I notice oh
that's not the case that fragment isn't
there I see it perfectly in my standard
but it's not present in my snack cake
and this is really common
um so a lot of bile acids for example
are known to contain this sort of uh so
three fragment and have masses very
similar to things like pfos and other
fluorochemicals so it's easy to sort of
fall into the Trap of potentially
reporting a false positive so when you
move to these alternative matrices
you're going to want to look at some of
these different fragments or use at
least a qualifier ion to be actually
confident in what you're looking at
specifically
um you know outside of the drinking
water world
but regardless when we're setting up
these methods another thing to sort of
pay attention to uh is just the points
across our Peak uh so when we go into
sex Os or whatever software you're using
whether it be sags or anywhere else
we're going to want to pay attention to
how many points across our Peak we're
reporting so generally we're going to
hope for 10 to 12. so if you look at the
right hand side which you'll see of
those little dots and each one of those
dots is a point when data was actually
collected and between those dots it's
just a straight line that's drawn
um from dot to Dot
so each one of those little points
represents one of those mrm experiments
I showed earlier so that's the data from
that mrm experiment and we're going to
want to make sure that we're doing 10 to
12 of those experiments across our Peak
as it's alluding so this really isn't an
issue
um with you know modern uh triple
quadrupoles they're very fast but if you
have a lot of things eluding at the same
time and you're not paying attention or
maybe your dwell time is is really high
it's something that you can kind of run
into this issue where you don't have
enough points across your Peak and you
can imagine you know if there are only
three points that say you end up with a
triangle and not something that's truly
gaussian or represents the actual peak
of Interest so something to pay
attention to something to kind of think
about when you're building out your pfas
method
another thing that's kind of unique to
quantifying pfas
um is let's take pfos for example so
pfos has a bunch of isomers we've got
these branched isomers and these linear
isomers and they'll allude at different
times if you have a really fast gradient
they can elude all at the same time if
that's your goal but most of the time
even with a relatively you know
slower gradient so something in the you
know 10 to 12 minutes you'll see the
separation which is great when reporting
these in regular methods most of the
time you're going to report it as a
total
which means you're going to want to
integrate all of these isomers some
regulated methods you know require them
to be reported separately but more than
likely it's going to be the total so
when you start to do this pfas analysis
or you're getting into this world and
you see these extra Peaks it's not
something to be alarmed by it's exactly
what we'd expect you're seeing those
different isomers and it can be really
cool when you look at something like a
biological sample because you'll see
these isomers in very different sort of
ratios so you can see the uptake differs
depending if it's branched or linear
which is which is kind of neat
but let's say you're going to move on
and you want to try some high resolution
Mass spectrometry so you've probably you
know if you're thinking about pfest or
you know investigating it uh you've
probably heard a lot about Discovery and
high resolution mass spectrometry and
sort of its role in this issue
so what's the difference between high
resolution mass spectrometry and nominal
mass and the first as you might guess
would be resolution
so when we think of a nominal Mass
instrument we're talking about a width
of about 0.7 Daltons so if I'm looking
at a compound with a mass of you know
100 I'm really looking at 100
with that sort of 0.7 Dalton
plus or minus around it
and because of that you know we can have
other compounds be hidden that's a
that's a big range right
um it's again we're being super specific
with nominal mass by doing mrm analysis
but still even in this scenario like
I've shown here with high resolution
Mass spectrometry we see there's
actually two compounds or two features
present uh underneath this sort of
nominal Mass Spectrum
so as we increase our resolution we sort
of get our more defined Peaks typically
for you know like a pewtoff for example
we'd be talking about 50 to 40 000
um resolution uh which is plenty uh for
pfas analysis
the other thing we're going to talk
about a little bit is just Mass accuracy
so these systems
um
have a high level of mass accuracy
compared to a nominal Mass system and
that's really just the difference
between the accurate Mass so the
measured Mass whatever you reported
based on your q-top
um or your nominal math system I suppose
versus the exact Mass where the exact
mass is actually the calculated Mass so
that would be if you took the formula
for pthos and calculated what its mass
should be and the difference between
these two is referred to mass accuracy
and for a high resolution instrument
we're talking about measuring to
.0001 Daltons versus again that that
nominal Mass where we're in the the unit
Mass range so it's typically on a
high-res system we're in the sub five
parts per million error
um often sub to
if we just take a quick review
um I'm just going to quickly go over how
these sort of experiments differ for you
and and just to kind of get an idea of
your head of what you're actually doing
um so we've got our mrm experiment on
our triple quad again that ion in this
case 4.99 it's making its way through so
this would be our pfos our pfos is
fragmenting in C2 or a collision cell
um Q2 sorry and our ions are making
their way into Q3 and we're going to
monitor for that 80 fragment we were
talking about earlier we're doing
drinking water we're not super worried
about something like a bile acid
interference
that ion's making its way through the
detector our triple quadrupole system
and go into the detector where we're
measuring intensity
so it has to differ from something like
a q Toff so for a q-top we're going to
select for an ion of Interest let's do
that 4.99
so our 4.99 or pfos is making its way
through just like it did in the previous
experiment it makes its way into the
clearing cell where fragmentation takes
place we're getting all our fragments
um but here's where it differs a little
bit instead of using a you know
quadrupole to filter out for a specific
fragment of Interest all of our
fragments are making their way into the
Toff analyzer
and what a Toth analyzer is or a
time-of-flight analyzer is essentially a
really good stopwatch and a really good
measuring tape so over the years we've
gotten really good at measuring time and
distance and because of that we can
actually calculate the mass of these
fragments based on how long it takes it
to reach our detector
um so we can do that really accurately
the other thing that's kind of
interesting here is that you notice all
of my fragrance made their way to the
detector just like on our triple
quadrupole we we optimized for that
temperature we optimized for our
Collision energy we optimize for a
clustering potential
um but because these tough analyzers are
so fast we can actually measure for all
of our ions and that's kind of cool and
I'll show you kind of why
so here we've got an example of pfbs and
you'll notice that not only do I have my
Peak like you're probably used to seeing
on the left hand side but I've got this
spectrum on the right hand side and
that's my library Spectrum
and because all of our ions are able to
hit that detector even though I've
optimized for let's say the 80 in this
case
um I can still see that 98 fragment and
because of that I can be really
confident and yes this is what I'm
looking at so if you think back to sort
of that scenario I showed you earlier
with that bile acid in the stack the
snake cake or something cake a snack
cake
um
we wouldn't be in that scenario
because we're going to be using the
accurate Mass so this is actually the
fragment Mass so that fragment at s is
less than 2 PPM so I'm happy that makes
sense in my standard compared to my
sample
um that's comparable I still am going to
be using retention time just like I
would on a triple quadrupole
but I'm using that Library match so sort
of that compounds fingerprint to be
really confident in what I'm looking at
and then I can still use that ion ratio
just like I would from a triple
quadrupole so I have all of these extra
pieces of evidence that make me
confident and yes this is definitely
pfps
and in fact if kind of going back uh in
time to That Snack cake here is that
data here so down below we have the pfal
Spectrum so this was from our library
and up top was that sort of mystery Peak
that was present yes it contained an 80
fragment you can see it's not as high in
abundance as some of the other fragments
but what you'll notice is comparing that
Spectrum that's in the green box the
purple Spectrum looks nothing like it so
that snack cake Spectrum looks nothing
like what the pfos Spectrum looks like
so on a triple quadrupole if I was only
looking at the quantifier item I didn't
have a qualifier
I would have a really hard time knowing
these were different
using the qualifier that really helped
so I was pretty confident that yes you
know this isn't that compound
and using a high resolution instrument
um I'm beyond confident you know I would
never get those two things and Confused
uh I wouldn't worry about it it just
adds a ton of confidence to me and my
data set
so hopefully that was a good little
overview of some of the things you might
expect as you sort of get into pfas
analysis these matrices are very
different and some can be really complex
and some can be really simple and
depending on what you're going after uh
your approach is going to need to change
not only from sample prep but just how
you consider your method right we talked
about sort of those interferences that
can happen with bile assets for example
so if you're doing food so
keep an eye out for those
um as we sort of
developed this you know new uh emerging
although that I would argue they've
already emerged uh issue of
fluorochemicals regulations are going to
change we're going to see sort of a
decrease in
logs Locus required reporting limits Etc
so keeping up with that is really
important we're also going to see a
change in sort of what we're monitoring
right if we think about the pfas life
cycle it's not as simple as just
drinking water it's landfills food
environment humans
uh it's a pretty complex web
but if you have any questions or you
know if you're interested in this please
reach out we've got a ton of application
scientists uh here at cyx who spent a
lot of time researching these um before
joining sex and currently wall ad sex
and it's something we love to talk about
so if you've got any questions please
use us as a resource it's something we
really enjoy
and with that I'm happy to take any
questions
great thank you Carl for your
informative presentation we will now
start the live q a portion of the
webinar you have a question you'd like
to ask please do so now just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen we'll answer as
many of your questions as we have time
for
so let's get started our first question
is are there specific solvents that you
would recommend that we use that are low
in pfas
yeah
um I've had some good luck with the lcms
grade solvents
um the thing I'll say is it's going to
kind of depend on what sort of compounds
you're interested in uh and my honestly
my best advice is to go ahead and try a
few so if you're just getting set up go
ahead and order a few different kinds of
solvents from a few different vendors
and take the you know half a day a
couple hours to see what your background
looks like with those solvents
great thank you another question here
asks can you use accurate mass for
regulated methods for example EPA 1633
yeah
um so no you're going to need to do a or
for the EPA 537 and 533 in 1633 you're
going to be needing to use a nominal
Mass instrument specifically a triple
quadrupole or Q trap So currently they
don't allow for acute off in those
regulated methods but
that being said if you're interested in
something else
[Music]
um
having accurate mass and the power of
you know resolution Mass accuracy is
going to just add to your confidence so
it depends a little bit but if you're
interested in those sort of regulated
drinking water methods then no you're
going to need to use a triple quadrupole
or a q-trap instrument
right
we have time for a few more questions
here so this next one asks can pfas be
found in food and if so are there any
regulations for pfas in food
yes uh so
um that's something I kind of get asked
every once in a while uh is there pfas
in food or is it pfest in the food
contact paper for example or the
packaging
um and the answer to that is both
um so yes you can find pfas and food and
yes you can find pfas in sort of that
contact paper packaging Etc
as of date there's really no regulations
uh at least not for the United States
surrounding peafas and food yet but I
imagine to see those coming in the next
couple years
feet
next question here asks are there
accurate Mass libraries we can use to
Aid in identifying unknown pfas
yeah
um so there are a couple at XIX we have
our fluorochemical library which is
pretty comprehensive myself and one of
my colleagues uh along with the Colorado
School of Mines did a lot of work in
iodine and discovering those compounds
so it's I think like nearly 300
compounds which is which is awesome
there are also other resources that
Norman suspect list exchange is an open
source resource where they have you know
lists of the expected sort of
fluorochemicals and even nist has a
really comprehensive list of expected uh
or predicted fluorochemicals that you
can look for so you have a few resources
there
great well we'll go ahead and wrap up
there so Carl I want to thank you again
for your time today and your important
research we would also like to thank lab
roots and our sponsor psyx for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
we did not have time for today and those
submitted during the on-demand period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand and
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time take care everyone
goodbye